Speaker 1: Let's go next to Adam from Knoxville,
Tennessee. Adam, welcome, sir.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Great to talk to you, sir.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 3: Hey, I have
a quick question about the the raid on Mar a
Lago. Sure. Are we going to get, like a press
release from the FBI kind of detailing exactly
what the evidentiary basis was for the raid?
Speaker 1: I have absolutely no idea. I
have absolutely no idea it. I mean, listen,
it's not a requirement that the FBI do that.
Sometimes the FBI on prominent cases will
brief the public as of this recording of, you
know, you and me talking now. That has not been
done. I'm very interested in knowing whether they
looked very strongly at elements of bathrooms
during the raid, and it's just not something that
they're telling us. So I want more information.
But honestly and by the way, listen, Donald Trump
can release the search warrant as well. I know
Lara Trump went on Fox News and said he doesn't
have it. Well, he might not physically have it,
but his lawyers obviously do. He can release the
search warrant at any time to prove how bogus
it all was. He's not chosen to do that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, right. And, you know,
I have some friends on the right and I'm a little
concerned that the basis wasn't super strong,
really. Like from an optics or political
standpoint, the right is going to use it
as like kind of a like a martyr dome for Trump.
Speaker 1: Well, of course. I mean, they're going
to do that no matter what. They've already been
saying he's the biggest victim of anybody ever.
You know, all this different stuff. So that's
I. Where are you? They will say that either way.
Where I agree with you, Adam, is it would
be really bad if there was not a strong
evidentiary basis for this. And so I am giving
the benefit of the doubt that if the attorney
general signed off on this, the FBI director
signed off on it, a judge signed off on it
until proven otherwise. I'm going to
assume that it was all done correctly.
But if that's not the case, I'll be the first
one here telling you that was not done right.
Speaker 3: Yep. Perfect. Thank
you. Can I ask you a quick cultural
question? Sure. Are you a fan of Astor Piazzolla?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, in a casual size,
I'm not like a connoisseur of his music.
For people wondering, Piazzolla was a very,
very well-known Argentinean tango singer. And
I don't know when do you know offhand? When he
died. How long has he been not around? No, it's.
Speaker 3: Been a while. He played. Was he a
singer? I thought he was more
of. He played the bandoneon.
Speaker 1: Oh, is that. He could.
Speaker 3: Have been a singer.
Speaker 1: Too. Yeah, you may be right. He
may not even have been a singer. But yeah,
I'm a fan of Argentinean tango. It's
sort of in my blood, as they say.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Astor Piazzolla is one
of my favorite musicians of all time.
Speaker 1: So beautiful. All right, well, Adam,
you sound like a man of culture. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David. Thanks for the time.
Speaker 1: Adam from Knoxville.
Very, very strongly participating in
today's show. You love to hear it.